you literally haven't said a word since
we got here yeah when i say i'm
meditating i'm just trying to figure out
what the fork is happening i think we
might be in an alien zoo or on a prank
show no jean you were dead whoa that's a
dope prank
got to give it up eleanor i told you
that first night that we were in a prank
show oh yeah
you did great job man
okay janet i have a question okay what
is the bad place like oh sorry that is
the one topic i'm not allowed to tell
you about i can only play you a brief
audio clip of what is happening there
right now okay
well it doesn't sound awesome
what is it with you in frozen yogurt
have you not heard of ice cream oh sure
but i've come to really like frozen
yogurt there's something so human about
taking something great and ruining it a
little so you can have more of it
look at all these dishes piling up
i used to just throw them in the sink
and they'd be magically cleaned by
morning i did that i cleaned the dishes
oh
then what's up with these bad boys you
are unbelievable
should we see magical trash bags
five more minutes flyers five more
minutes oh man really
we need a plan i say we just lie low and
hope that they don't notice me i'm sorry
i don't think i can help you i just
don't like being dishonest and i can't
advise you to be dishonest either come
on i'm just asking you to fudge a little
bit you must have told a few white lies
in your life i mean what was your job i
was a professor of ethics and moral
philosophy mother forker
i'm getting a stomachache
i'm in a perfect utopia and i have a
stomachache i can't believe they've
managed to mix one million flavors
together and yet somehow i can taste
each individual one it's remarkable i
got no flavor
it's all i deserve really no look i i
appreciate you trying to cheer me up i
really do but you don't understand th
this was the very first neighborhood
that i got to design it was my chance to
prove myself and now i've blown it you
know sometimes a floor can make
something even more beautiful like with
cindy crawford and how short she is oh
tahani if i made one tiny mistake in my
design if there's a single glitch in the
system if even one blade of grass is
angled a a fraction of a degree off
the whole neighborhood is
compromised
whose dog is that guys whose dog is that
whose dog is dad
see
this is one of those glitches i was
talking about nice try puppy
that was a close one
teacup
hey
have you seen my dog
[Music]
so here's the situation avita
i kind of kicked your dog into the sun
but i got her back
everything
everything seems fine teacup thank
goodness you're okay everyone it is
merely a construct of a dog it feels no
pain or joy or love
teacup doesn't love me
oh
oh no no no no it definitely feels love
do you actually want a dog that loves
you a little bit more because i can kick
her right back into the sun and get you
another one just like that no oh
we've been torturing each other since
the moment we arrived
and everything michael has done has made
at least one of us miserable he played
us like a fiddle
you